good afternoon show of hands how many of
you think the the benefits of early
childhood education far exceed the cost
of the investment and were under
estimating in early childhood education
in this country right you're the wrong
audience it may seem a little strange
having a banker come and talk to you
about the value of early childhood
education but please understand that
this is very much an economic issue and
it's actually at the heart of having a
prosperous and successful economy and
society a few years back I was actually
asked if I would do a research paper on
the state of literacy and numeracy in
Canada now I couldn't believe we could
actually have a problem because we have
a modern knowledge-based economy we have
a well-developed primary and secondary
school system right how could we
possibly have a problem on something so
basic as literacy and numeracy well the
international statistics proved
enormously shocking to me to find that
that close to five and ten Canadian
adults don't have the desired level of
literacy to succeed in a modern
knowledge-based economy and close to six
in ten don't have the most the desired
level of numeracy I remember you know we
have a we have an awareness problem in
the country about this state of affairs
because like myself when I went into
doing research in this area most
Canadians can't believe we have a
problem here I remember having doing a
TV interview on on this after I you know
did my report and I was doing the
interview and I said to the the reporter
you know I actually have people you know
in my family that don't meet the desired
criteria right if you ever told them
that they had a problem they'd get
really upset with you I got off the
program and phone rings immediately it's
my mother-in-law who says who
alright and the reality is that the the
most recent data suggests that we aren't
actually seeing any improvement even
though we're doing increased investment
in the space and it's terribly depressed
by the more recent Pisa numbers on on
numeracy and math math skills of our
youth that actually showed it to the
deterioration so you know why do I care
about essential skills development well
from an economist point of view you know
the way I would look at it is just you
know it increases the odds of being
employed it reduces unemployment if you
have you experienced unemployment the
duration of unemployment is cut if you
have stronger essential skills it
increases range of occupations you can
fill it lifts lifetime earnings it helps
you do training it raises your standard
of living in actual fact I think it's
the grain a blur it's what you build
everything else on so a very fundamental
question is okay if we're not doing well
where do we invest to change things well
I do a lot of financial planning
presentations around this time of year
being RSP season and I actually don't
have a problem conveying to investors
the value of compounding interest and
compounding returns right well the
message here is you invest early and the
more you invest early the better the
return you're going to get on your
investment it works the same way with
education all right if you invest
earlier you're going to get a big payoff
and there's benefits you know when we
think about early childhood education
people immediately lead to you know the
benefits to the child but let's
understand there's also benefits to the
economy society and parents as well so
this is it has a broad base effect and
there's been a lot of research done and
they eat and you heard about it today
and from experts you know which I am NOT
that an awful lot of child development
happens or awful lot of personal
development happens in early stage in
life one of the status that statistics I
found most interesting when I was going
through the the literature on the
subject was the fact that more and more
we believe the environment shapes your
skill sets you know it's not driven by
by pure genetics right and and
the outcomes can be altered by
intervention and early at an early stage
and it's much easier to develop early
then try to fix later in life so it
leads to better outcomes and I'm not you
know unfortunately when I was thought I
was going to speak for 10 minutes i said
i don't want slides I don't like slides
it distracts the audience from what
you're saying and they said no no no we
want exhibits we want charts right the
problem is you put charts in and I think
it makes the presentation longer so I'm
going to be very brief in a lot of the
slides so it you know what we can see is
kids have gone through effective early
childhood programs have lower grade
retentions they are you know there's
less need for special education it
lowers high school dropout rates
participants in the program's know you
always got to be careful correlation and
causation but the correlation here is
kids have been through these programs
tend to have make better life decisions
from a society point of view you say
okay so who in society is the most
vulnerable population right and the
answer is kids from lower income
backgrounds but there's a caveat to this
and that is you don't want your early
childhood education programs to be just
filled with kids from low-income
families because the the literature
actually shows that doesn't actually end
up with optimal outcomes you actually
want diverse sets of kids in the
classrooms but if you had to say you
know who are the people that are most
vulnerable the obvious answer is low
income kids and since we're having an
increased dialogue around income
inequality in and out comes along those
lines this discussion actually fits into
that theme as well the the impact on the
economy you know there is a wide array
right one of the most obvious one is it
increases female labor participation now
the gap between male and female labor
participation has closed enormously over
the years and I've had a big long debate
with with my former boss Don Drummond
about how much more that could close but
if you look at look at the female
participation with kids less than six
years old what you'll find is there is
scope there that you could have you
could have some narrowing but it goes
way beyond that right we as a country
need the most skilled labor force we can
possibly produce the populations aging
labor force is slowing this is going to
leave labor shortages right almost all
the jobs out there are going to be for
post-secondary education graduates and
the economy is constantly changing the
speed at which things happen is
incredible and this means you need to
constantly upgrade your skills you don't
go to school and then stop and go work
you go work and continue to learn as you
go and workers have to be adaptable they
have to be able to change careers right
and from economy point of view if we try
to compete with places like China on
labor costs we will lose so how are you
going to win the answer is you have to
go up the the the scale in producing
more sophisticated products but that
means you need more sophisticated labor
and if we look at Canada one of our
biggest economic challenges is
enormously poor productivity growth now
it's a conundrum to economists as to why
our productivity growth is as bad as it
actually is we don't have a you know a
good answer for for what's caused it but
like a good murder mystery we have a
bunch of good suspects right and we're
under investing in capital is one
example but the flip side the reciprocal
that is we're more reliant on labor
right and that means we need the labor
that has the skills to drive the economy
and there are big benefits to parents
you know probably the one that that that
is the most understated is the impact
that that that early childhood education
can provide in reducing stress on
parents and all the knock-on effects
from that so and then from a society
point of view you know we spend a lot of
money dealing with consequences of
people trapped and low-income and and
not being successful and you know if we
there was a study done that looked at
what's the cost for every high school
grad school dropout all right well if we
can lower house go if we can lower the
dropout rate we can take that money and
actually use it for other things which
is actually going to be a more effective
and a better outcome
for our economy in society now you're
having a presentation from an economist
so you had didn't expect that basically
we're going to get down to dollars and
cents and you know in today's very
fiscal fiscally responsible behind you
that's going to come in the office
immediately after and say I've gotten
equally if not more important cause for
you to invest in so I think from us from
an advocacy point of view it's it is
really important to have numbers behind
you know what's the return on the
investment if you have a dollar and you
spend it where are you going to get the
best return so my team did an evaluation
we went through all the different
literature that had been written on this
subject and it's amazing like out of 60
studies there was only one I came across
where there was a case of a negative
return assessment and that one that one
study when you dug below the surface
what it told you was it was the quality
of the program the other 59 said that
the benefits far outweigh the costs and
in terms of giving you a range on this
the the benefit cost ratio was anywhere
from every dollar you invest you get a
dollar fifty all the way up to almost
three dollars that's um that's a massive
return the one thing I would caution um
for any of you that are doing advocacy
is don't ever don't oversell your case
because it will actually undermine you
right so when we looked at these studies
we tried to understand how they were
done was the numbers done in a unbiased
manner that was you know was the data
handled responsibly and so you know
there's a lot of things that go into
those numbers right you know costs can
overrun what your plan costs are the
benefits are often very hard to quantify
so you know we're taking hard numbers
here but at the same time you know what
this is a little loosey-goosey so when I
looked at it you know I'm much more
comfortable with the dollar and
d return vs a dollar but I think a lot
of people you know immediately goes go
to the three dollar return because hey
that makes my case better understand a
fifty percent return on your investment
how would you like that in your
portfolio fifty percent is a great
return right you don't have to go all
the way to three hundred percent to
actually you know make your case alright
so the bottom line the thing I want to
stress though is all of the studies tell
you the same thing high quality early
childhood education carries enormous
benefits relative to the the costs that
are going to be that are going to go
into the outcome and when we think about
the country you know I really do think
that there's an inequality dimension to
this how many of you believe that we
should have universal primary school in
Canada right most virtuous one this so
why do we think we should leave parents
to fend for themselves with kids up to
age four or five right like if you use
the logic and you just work backwards
and say you know should should access to
education which again I think education
is the great enabler right should should
that be universal if you think the
answer is yes then you have to ask
yourself why you know why did the
systems you know why is the system
starting when it's starting so the
bottom line is I think increased
investment in this area would be
enormously impactful and when I think
about when I look at canada i look at
public expenditure on early childhood
education as a share of the economy and
we look at this as a comparison between
other english-speaking countries and
western european countries and we
compare them to canada canada ranks dead
last there isn't actually that many
other areas that you can find canada
ranks dead last right so it is very
clear and and actually just to emphasize
this point this includes Quebec
right so if you move outside of the
Quebec area that where you have a
program in place the canadian numbers
even look worse so what would it take to
get canada to the average of OECD
nations not above it that's just the
average well the answer is it would cost
about three to four billion dollars and
then the question is okay so now we have
governments in Canada that are working
against binding fiscal constraints right
the the federal government probably will
balance its budget in 2015 if not 2014 I
personally think it's gonna be 2014 but
the provinces you know many of the
provinces like Ontario actually faced
much tougher fiscal challenges and from
an advocacy point of view I think that
the message here is you we need to drive
home the point the value of of
investment in the space but when you're
talking to the government you also have
to be pragmatic in terms of
understanding what the fiscal
constraints are going to be but in terms
of making the case what you really need
to do is make the case that there's a
more efficient way of using the
resources we have and from a point of
view of you know when as balanced as
budgets are being balanced and
governments are looking at reforming
their spending you know they should be
thinking about where are they going to
get the biggest bang for their buck and
in my opinion early childhood education
is one of those areas where it will have
it would have a very large long-term
impact I often get pushed back about you
know should you spend three or four
billion dollars on early childhood
education or should you spend it on
skills development for for workers today
to deal with shortages today and the
answer is yes right you have to do both
right businesses are going to need
workers today but we're also going to
need the workers of the future and you
need to be able to balance that if
you're going to be successful in the
long run
take left we were going to overcome a
lot of the other challenges that we have
to face so I'll stop there and I look
forward to any questions
you